economía en france 24 me acompañan en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches comenzamos hablando de los
protagonistas del caso game stop que
rindieron cuentas ante el congreso de
eeuu cómo les fue hola santiago pues
recordemos que ese fue un caso que
sacudió a la bolsa de nueva york- y
provocó investigaciones por parte de
varias agencias federales y estatales
pero démosle un repaso a través de un
foro en una red social llamada red y
miles de pequeños inversionistas se
pusieron de acuerdo para invertir en la
empresa de videojuegos gamestop y en
otras empresas
de esta manera dispararon el precio de
las acciones pero muchos de los grandes
fondos de inversión privada de
wallstreet apostaban a que esas mismas
acciones bajarán por eso la jugada de
unos cuantos les hizo perder miles de
millones de dólares y cuando todos
pensaban que este caso ya era cosa del
pasado pues el congreso decidió citar a
los protagonistas de esta escandalosa
saga escuchémoslos
es cierto que mi inversión en esa
empresa multiplicó su valor muchas veces
y por eso me siento enormemente
afortunado
no soy un inversor institucional ni un
fondo de inversión privada no tengo
clientes y no abriendo asesoría
personalizada de inversión por
honorarios o comisiones solo soy una
persona cuya inversión en gamestop y
publicaciones en las redes sociales se
basaron en mi propia investigación y
análisis ahora escuchemos lo que opinan
los representantes de los grandes fondos
de inversión tomaron información
contenida en nuestras presentaciones
ante la sec y alentaron a otros a
negociar en la dirección opuesta
muchas de estas publicaciones estaban
mezcladas con insultos antisemitas
dirigidos a mí el mensaje decía cosas
como está muy claro que necesitamos un
segundo holocausto los judíos no pueden
seguir saliéndose con la suya
daniela pasamos a temas de américa
latina- bolivia le devolvió un
millonario préstamo al fondo
monetariointernacional en plena crisis
de pandemia
santiago esto es un crédito por 346
puntos 7 millones de dólares gestionado
hace nueve meses por el gobierno
transitorio de jeanine áñez para atender
la crisis sanitaria el banco central de
bolivia dice ahora que este préstamo
además de ser irregular y oneroso por
sus condiciones financieras generó
costos económicos adicción
por más de 24 millones de dólares hasta
febrero y anunció que entablará acciones
administrativas civiles y penales además
de la devolución el fondo monetario
internacional hay que decirlo es
bastante impopular en la región por las
estrictas medidas a las que condicionan
sus préstamos en ecuador' el candidato
de izquierda que ganó en primera vuelta
andrés araus dijo que ha tenido
acercamientos con el organismo y
argentina también está negociando un
acuerdo para reestructurar su deuda
pasemos ahora a hablar de los
agricultores de dos islas que están en
el caribe que demandaron al gobierno
francés porque mire la historia santiago
hay un pesticida llamado cloro de kona
que hace casi medio siglo fue prohibido
en eeuu porque se le atribuyen problemas
como contaminación daños neurológicos en
las personas e incluso cáncer de
próstata en francia su uso es ilegal
desde 1990 sin embargo bajo una exención
especial se usó durante tres años más
para combatir el gorgojo de banano en
dos de sus territorios de ultramar estoy
de las islas guadalupe y martinica en el
caribe que tienen unos 750.000
habitantes un tribunal de parís
desempolvó una demanda interpuesta en
2006 contra el gobierno francés y
escucho en audiencia a los agricultores
de la zona y también a los
ambientalistas ellos dicen que esa
extensión era ilegal y que los envenenó
porque la contaminación de esa sustancia
podría durar décadas después de su
prohibición el gobierno francés tiene
previsto incrementar el presupuesto para
combatir esa contaminación pero no es
suficiente para los demandantes porque
dicen que en su momento no los
protegieron como debía pasemos ahora los
indicadores cómo les va las principales
bolsas en la forma santiago o street
tuvo pérdidas después de conocerse que
están subiendo otra vez las solicitudes
de subsidios por desempleo esta misma
situación impactó a la baja a las bolsas
europeas y en américa latina hubo saltos
rojos en brasil colombia y argentina y
pasamos a la cifra el día para el cierre
son 2 mil 133 millones de euros que
perdió el fabricante europeo de aviones
hervás en 2020
la atención es que en 2019 cuando no
había pandemia había perdido más en
total perdió 1.362 millones de euros
en ese año santiago antes de la pandemia
cuando no había comenzado la crisis en
la industria de la aviación gracias
daniela por esta información es todo por
el momento aquí en la economía en
france24 siga con nosotros
[Música]